[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen es gibt so Momente
da geht einem der Puls das sind
gleichzeitig die Momente die man nie
mehr vergisst im Leben die
Führerscheinprüfung ein Heiratsantrag
bei Fußballprofis der entscheidende
Elfmeter in der Politik ist es die Wahl
in ein hohes Amt wenn die mühsam
geschmiedete Koalition steht und sich
nun beweisen muss ob sie hält
Kai Wegner wollte heute neue Regierender
Bürgermeister von Berlin werden mit den
Stimmen seiner neuen Koalition aus CDU
und SPD zweimal ist der durchgefallen
erst im dritten Wahlgang als die
einfache Mehrheit reichte hat es
geklappt ich spreche gleich mit ihm erst
stellen Stefan Merseburger und Markus
groß den neuen vor und die gewaltigen
Probleme die auf ihn warten
Kai Wegner der lang unterschätzte
endlich am Ziel die Schornsteinfeger
sollen das ist Tradition in Berlin Glück
bringen und das wird er brauchen
Bürgermeister nur wie ein Tag zum
Vergessen und trotzdem historisch
heute um 8.30 die Limousine gepanzert
erstmals hat er noch nicht ganz
Bürgermeister Personenschutz Vorfreude
und auch Vorahnung
ein ganz wichtig ein ganz bedeutender
Tag für mich gar keine Frage dass ich
jetzt gar nicht nervös wäre das wäre
auch nicht die ganze Wahrheit die
Wahrheit ist es kommt richtig dick
erster Dämpfer um kurz vor eins ja
stimmt 71 Nein stimmen 86
Enthaltungen eine damit das Kai Wegener
nicht gewählt
die Gesichter lang doch damit konnten
sie noch rechnen im ersten Wahlgang
dann der zweite ich darf das Ergebnis
der Wahl zum Regierenden Bürgermeister
von Berlin verkündet damit ist kein
Wegener nicht gewählt jetzt herrscht
pures Entsetzen und zwischen CDU und SPD
beginnt die Suche nach den abweichland
schuldig ist natürlich der andere
aus Teilen der SPD ist ja auch
kommuniziert worden dass Kai Wegener für
sie ein Problem ist und da mache ich das
ein Stück weit auch fest ich könnte nur
sagen ich hoffe dass Kai Wegner jetzt in
diesen Minuten seine rein schießen kann
war Gang 3 das Ergebnis kommt um viertel
fünf
Bürgermeister von Berlin gewählt und
trotzdem will keine Freude aufkommen was
für eine Hängepartie und es kommt noch
schlimmer die AFD behauptet Wegener
gewählt zu haben eine Finte Tatsache
beides möglich zu beweisen ist weder das
eine noch das andere das Kai Wegner
den Verdacht nicht mehr los wird dass er
jetzt mit den Stimmen der AFD zum
Regierenden Bürgermeister gewählt worden
ist das hätte schwarz rot niemals
riskieren dürfen 86 Stimmen hat diese
Koalition und 86 Stimmen haben heute
dann am Schluss mit Jahr gestimmt ich
glaube dass die AFD hier kautisieren
will die AFD ist keine Demokratie
freundliche Partei
wie immer ist auch gewesen sein mag
diese Senat hat sich selbst verschuldet
in eine heftige Krisensituation
manövriert das ist keine Liebesheirat
werden würde war von vorne rein klar
aber so viel Qual dieser Staat ist ein
Desaster da hilft auch kein Lächeln
und hier ist er der neue live im heute
journal herrigierender Bürgermeister
guten Abend
schönen guten Abend wir zwei haben am
Wahlabend hier im heute schon mal
miteinander gesprochen da wussten sie
noch nicht so genau was sie darauf
wetten sollten dass sie tatsächlich
Regierender Bürgermeister werden jetzt
hat es geklappt aber doch mit
erheblichen Hindernissen ist das jetzt
eine Vorausahnung auf eine ziemlich
unruhige Regierungszeit
nein das glaube ich nicht wir haben
einen tollen Koalitionsvertrag gemeinsam
zwischen CDU und SPD ausgehandelt auf
einmal 135 Seiten gute Lösungen für die
Probleme für die Herausforderung aber
für die Chancen in unserer Stadt wir
haben jetzt gerade die erste
Senatssitzung gehabt ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass die nächsten
dreieinhalb Jahre richtig gut werden und
gerade für Berlin lassen Sie uns noch
kurz über diesen Tag reden bitte haben
Sie mal überlegt diesen dritten Wahlgang
nicht zu machen einer ihre Vorgänger
Klaus Wowereit der hatte 2006 auch
Probleme ist erst im zweiten Wahlgang
gewählt worden und er hat dann hinterher
gesagt einen dritten hätte er nicht
gemacht
naja das sind Möglichkeiten die die
Verfassung vorsehen die Geschäftsordnung
und ich habe mich für den dritten
Wahlgang entschieden auch nach
Rücksprache mit meiner Fraktion auch
nach Rücksprache mit der SPD-Fraktion
und ich war mit ziemlich sicher dass im
dritten Wahlgang unsere
Koalitionsmehrheit steht und das war ja
dann am Ende auch so allerdings ist es
auch so dass die AFD jetzt behauptet sie
habe für sie gestimmt und sie haben das
Problem dass sie den weil sie eine
geheime Wahl war den Verdacht einfach
nicht ausräumen können nur mit Stimmen
der AFD an der Macht zu sein
möglicherweise
ja aber ich glaube das schlicht der AFD
nicht dass sie mich gewählt haben
die AFD hat gar keinen Grund einen
Regierenden Bürgermeister zu wählen
einen Senat ins Amt zu verhelfen wo wir
eine Justiz Senatorin haben die so
ziemlich die stärkste afd-jägerin hier
im Land ist
aber die AFD sagt so was die Frage ist
ja jetzt wie sauer sind sie denn auf die
eigenen Reihen auf ihre eigene Koalition
dass sie eben diesen dritten Wahlgang
gebraucht haben weil es vorher nicht
klappte
na dass das kein guter Start für diese
Koalition war es doch völlig unstrittig
wir hatten wirklich gute
Koalitionsverhandlungen gute
Sondierungsgespräche und das war jetzt
kein guter Auftakt für den dritten
Wahlgang braucht das ist kein guter
Start aber wir haben ja jetzt alles
Chancen in den nächsten dreieinhalb
Jahren dafür zu sorgen das besser zu
machen und das werden wir tun war das
ein Protest gegen sie oder gegen Frau
ihre koalitionspartnerin
das kann ich gar nicht bewerten das hat
auf jeden Fall nicht im ersten und
zweiten Wahlgang gereicht und jetzt
geht's darum die
koalitionsabgeordneten zu überzeugen
aber ganz ehrlich was mir viel wichtiger
ist ist die Berlinerinnen und Berliner
zu überzeugen dass wir eine gute Arbeit
machen wie hat man sich denn diese
Arbeit jetzt ganz konkret vorzustellen
wenn man eine Regierende Bürgermeisterin
ablöst deren Büro ja auch dann mit dem
heutigen Tag bekommt sie aber gemeinsam
mit einem selbst weitermacht nur eben
nicht mehr als Regierende
Bürgermeisterin sondern als Senatorin
ja das haben wir sehr gut geregelt wir
hatten heute die Amtsübergabe und ich
darf Ihnen sagen dass Franziska Giffey
und ich wir haben ein sehr gutes
freundschaftliches Verhältnis entwickelt
auch und gerade in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen der sehr viel
Vertrauen aufgebaut und das gilt für die
gesamte senatsmannschaft und deswegen
bin ich ganz sicher dass wir richtig gut
zusammenarbeiten werden es wird nicht
der Streit überwiegen sondern
pragmatische Lösungen für diese Stadt
und darauf hat Berlin so lange gewartet
ihr Generalsekretär hat einen sehr
schönen Satz gesagt nämlich ich zitiere
ihn eine Vernunft Ehe kennt zumindest
keine Eifersuchtsdramen das mag stimmen
nur sie glänzt eben halt auch nicht
[Musik]
es waren sehr verkürzter Lebenslauf
ihrer Seite das gehört bei der Anführer
aber da gehört noch viel mehr dazu
selbstverständlich aber es ist ja doch
ein ein Staat in eine Politkarriere die
jetzt nicht jeder hat
nein aber das zeigt einmal mehr und das
ist mir auch wichtig dass man mit Fleiß
mit Engagement Ziele verfolgen kann und
Ziel auch erreichen kann und ich will
dafür sorgen gerade durch eine gute
Bildungspolitik dass das
aufstiegsversprechen unserer
Gesellschaft das ist funktionieren kann
dass Menschen aufsteigen können in
andere Ebenen sich hocharbeiten können
ich bin vielleicht ein ganz gutes
Beispiel und ich will dafür sorgen dass
das allen Kindern und Jugendlichen in
unserer Stadt so geht egal woher sie
kommen egal wo sie geboren sind jetzt
haben sie eine Verwaltung auf
Landesebene aber auch auf Bezirksebene
vor allem in Berlin die von vielen auch
von vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern immer
wieder als komplett dysfunktional
beschrieben wird sie haben im Wahlkampf
versprochen dass wieder fit zu machen
ist es das woran sie am Ende gemessen
werden wollen und müssen
dadurch aus ich will daran auch gemessen
werden wir wollen eine Verwaltungsreform
wir wollen die Digitalisierung
vorantreiben ich glaube hier wurde viel
zu viel darüber gesprochen und jetzt
müssen wir mal machen wir haben tolle
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
öffentlichen Verwaltungen in Berlin ob
im Land oder in den Bezirken und jetzt
geht es darum für Strukturen zu sorgen
dass die Dienstleistung für die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner bracht werden
können ich mache das zur Chef sage ich
hole mir das in diese nachtskanzlei
deswegen muss ich mich daran noch messen
lassen jetzt müssen wir mal machen sagt
der künftige Regierende Bürgermeister
von Berlin Herr Wegner herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch heute Abend live bei
uns
ich danke Ihnen und nachher dieser
Hinweis noch im heute journal Update
Fragen von wolfsmiese an den fraktions-
und Landesvorsitzenden der Berliner SPD
lohnt sich dabei zu sein so noch eine
Wahl jetzt eine die enorme Folgen haben
könnte für die Türkei und für die Welt
weil die Türkei ein wichtiges Land ist
und wer sie regiert das hat gleich für
ganz viele Krisen entscheidende
Bedeutung seit 20 Jahren regiert immer
derselbe Rezept Erdogan doch am 14 Mai
kann er nicht sicher sein ob das so
bleibt sein gegen Kandidat Kemal Kilic
da Rollo schlägt sich gut in den
Umfragen Erdogan muss außerdem gerade
eine Reihe von Wahlkampfauftritten
absagen weil er gesundheitlich nicht auf
der Höhe ist
seit heute können 3,4 Millionen im
Ausland lebende Türkinnen und Türken
ihre Stimme abgeben fasst die Hälfte von
ihnen lebt bei uns in Deutschland
Stefanie gagusch
hoffnungsvoll die Stimmung bei den
Unterstützern der größten
Oppositionspartei der CHP in Berlin im
kurzzeitig eröffneten Wahllokal
mobilisieren sie für ihre Koalition aus
sechs Parteien gegen Erdogan
wir wollen eine demokratische Türkei wir
wollen wieder Demokratie mit allen
Institutionen einrichten und das ist mit
er da nicht mehr möglich wir sind
ziemlich sicher dass wir dieses Mal
schaffen werden er ist der Kandidat des
Bündnisses
von der CRP umfragen zur Folge hat der
gute Chancen Erdogan abzulösen dieser
erfährt Gegenwind wegen des verheerenden
Erdbebens der hohen Inflation der
stockendenwirtschaft zudem scheint der
gesundheitlich angeschlagen brach dieses
Interview gestern ab all dies kommt auch
bei ihnen in Deutschland an
ich bin deutsch Türkin hier geboren ich
habe mir jetzt einen Ausweis im
türkischen Ausweis zum ersten Mal
erstellen lassen weil ich wählen möchte
weil ich das diesmal unterstützen möchte
dass er geht in der Vergangenheit
stimmte die Mehrheit der Auslandstürken
stets für Erdogan und seine Partei die
AKP und wenn wir uns die Ergebnisse der
letzten Wahlen angucken dann sehen wir
dass die AKP bei den letzten Wahlen über
60 Prozent teilweise auch im Ruhrgebiet
in Deutschland in verschiedenen Städten
bei 70 oder 75% lag da sehen wir
durchaus dass die AKP weiter diese Kraft
behalten möchten noch 2014 umwarb
Erdogan deshalb die türkischen Wähler in
Deutschland persönlich solche
Veranstaltungen sind längst nicht mehr
erlaubt dass er Wahlkampf aber hinter
verschlossenen Türen weitergehen belegt
die Hassrede eines AKP Abgeordneten im
Januar dieses Jahres in einer Moschee
neues
die UID das Sprachrohr der AKP
distanziert sich von der Rede die
Organisation wird vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet der Wahlkampf wurde danach
ruhiger im Netz finden sich aber
weiterhin viele Veranstaltungen Fasten
brechen mit einem AKP Abgeordneten in
Köln oder mit dem Vorsitzenden der UID
in Düsseldorf alles kulturelle
Ereignisse oder nette Treffen sagte der
Pressesprecher
wir betreiben überhaupt gar keinen
Wahlkampf das sind hauptsächlich
freundschaftliche Besuche und wenn man
sich das ganz genau noch mal angucken
möchte sind das tatsächlich Abgeordnete
die entweder die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft besitzen und
möglicherweise noch ein Zweitwohnsitz in
Deutschland haben anderes beobachtet
Kemal busay vom Zentrum für
radikalisierungsforschung das ist alles
Wahlkampf was die
UID die dtip und andere Strukturen und
gläubigeorganisationen hier gestalten
gerade auch im Sinne von
kulturfestfesten Kulturveranstaltungen
moschee-runden so schwappen nun mit der
Wahl die Probleme und auch die
Polarisierung in der Türkei nach
Deutschland
das ist eine Wahl auf die wir genau
schauen werden auch wir hier natürlich
am 14 Mai kommt das heute journal live
aus Ankara
so jetzt der Blick auf weitere
Nachrichten heute in der Übersicht und
die hast du Hanna ja ganz genau die
Bundesregierung will mehr ausländische
Fachkräfte nach Deutschland holen und
die Hürden dafür senken heute hat der
Bundestag über den Gesetzentwurf dazu
debattiert und zwar kontrovers die
Ampelkoalition plant ein Punktesystem
nach kanadischem Vorbild die Union
kritisierte unter anderem das damit eine
Einwanderung der minder qualifizierten
gefördert werde Arbeitsminister Heil
verteidigte das Vorhaben und betonte
dass alles getan werden müsse um dem
Arbeitskräftemangel zu begegnen
nach ihrem evakuierungseinsatz hat die
Bundeswehr den Sudan wieder verlassen im
Rahmen der Rückverlegung konnte die
Luftwaffe weitere 65 Menschen in
Sicherheit bringen unterdessen setzen
einige Länder die Evakuierung fort vor
allem per Schiff im Sudan selbst gehen
die Kämpfe trotz vereinbarter Waffenruhe
zwischen Armee und RSF Mili zweiter die
USA und die Afrikanische Union haben in
dem Konflikt ihre Vermittlung angeboten
nach der Amok Tat in einer Hamburger
Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas bei der im
März sieben Menschen getötet wurden wird
nun gegen einen Mitarbeiter der
Hamburger Waffenbehörde ermittelt wegen
des Verdachts der fahrlässigen Tötung
laut Generalstaatsanwaltschaft soll der
Behörden Mitarbeiter über den
Sportschützenverein des Täters
Informationen über dessen psychischen
Zustand erhalten haben statt diese
weiterzugeben empfahl er daraufhin
offenbar ein anonymes Schreiben an die
Behörde zu senden auch gegen drei
Mitglieder des Vereins wird ermittelt
wegen des Anfangsverdachts der
falsch-urkundung im Amt
der mutmaßliche Angreifer der vergangene
Woche in einem Duisburger Fitnessstudio
vier Menschen mit einem Messer schwer
verletzt haben soll steht unter
dringendem Tatverdacht bereits Tage
zuvor einen 35-Jährigen erstochen zu
haben das hat die Düsseldorfer
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt
Grundlage sein DNA-Spuren die an
abgeglichen werden wurden der 26-Jährige
Syrer sitzt in Untersuchungshaft erst am
Dienstag hatten die Ermittler bekannt
gegeben das ist bei der Tat in dem
Fitnessstudio Hinweise auf einen
islamistisches Motiv gebe
die Nachrichten aus Afghanistan sind
selten gut sie lesen sich aktuell aber
noch alarmierender als sonst ohnehin
schon für jede zweite Familie dort gehe
es jetzt praktisch ums Überleben sagt
heute das Welternährungsprogramm der
Vereinten Nation
gleichzeitig wird nicht nur für die
Menschen unter der Taliban Herrschaft
die Lage prehera auch für die
Hilfsorganisationen aus aller Welt es
ist nicht leicht aus Afghanistan zu
berichten ZDF Reporterin Katrin
Eugendorf ist dort
es ist eine ganz und gar ungewöhnliches
Szene für afghanische Verhältnisse und
sie zeigt wie groß die Verzweiflung ist
Frauen die versuchen in einer
Ausgabestelle des
un-welternährungsprogramms zu drängen
Männer die alle Mühe haben für Ordnung
zu sorgen
sie haben uns gesagt dass die Hilfe die
wir bekommen jetzt eingestellt wird die
Situation ist nicht gut alle Frauen die
in der Schlange stehen haben
wirtschaftliche Probleme
Philipp Kopf der Sprecher des
Welternährungsprogramms der UN zeigt mir
die Nahrungsmittel eine siebenköpfige
Familie erhält 50 kg Mehl 6 Kilo Linsen
4,5 Liter Öl und Salz eine Ration für
zwei Wochen 23 Millionen Menschen haben
die Vereinten Nationen in den
vergangenen 20 Monaten versorgt doch nun
steht die weitere Finanzierung der
Afghanistan Nothilfe in Frage
kein neues Geld mehr erhalten
wir mussten die Unterstützung von 13
Millionen Menschen in diesem Monat auf 5
Millionen Menschen reduzieren und wenn
kein neues Geld reinkommt dann ist Ende
Mai die letzte distribution in
Afghanistan wie ist das für sie als der
hier verantwortliche
sie haben mit Menschen draußen geredet
denn unsere Kollegen Kolleginnen sagen
mussten ihr kriegt kein Essen mehr das
ist der Horror das will man nicht machen
ohne humanitäre Nothilfe droht 19
Millionen Menschen der Hunger
54% der kleinen Kinder sind unterernährt
die dramatische Versorgungskrise
herrscht nicht mehr nur auf dem Land
sondern auch in der Hauptstadt es gibt
Lebensmittel doch immer weniger Menschen
können sie sich leisten und die Arbeit
der internationalen Hilfsorganisationen
wird zunehmend schwieriger seitdem die
Taliban verfügt haben dass Frauen nicht
mehr für sie arbeiten dürfen stehen
viele vor allem die Lämmer sollen sie
ihre Arbeit einstellen
werden wir aber nicht unsere
Unterstützung einstellen wir können
diese Millionen Hungernden Menschen
inklusive der Hälfte Frauen und Mädchen
und ready most verletzlich
ist nicht im Stich lassen die Frauen die
draußen in der Schlange warten haben
bereits fast alles verloren ihren Job
ihre Rechte nun drohen sie auch das
letzte zu verlieren erzählen Sie uns
wir können nichts machen wenn Sie Ihre
Hilfe einstellen ich weiß nicht was uns
dann noch bleibt
so sehr die Not drängt eine dauerhafte
Lösung der humanitären Lage bieten Mehl
und Reis nicht doch wie das Land
dauerhaft unterstützen eine Frage der
sich die Vereinten Nationen stellen
müssen
geht zurück nach Deutschland und einem
Problem dass wir ja alle hier spüren und
dass sich jetzt mit konkreten Zahlen
belegen lässt Hanna trotz Lohnerhöhungen
konnten sich die Deutschen im
vergangenen Jahr deutlich weniger
leisten als bisher angenommen laut dem
Statistischen Bundesamt sind die
Reallöhne 2022 um ganze vier Prozent
gesunken das ist stärker als gedacht
Valerie Haller was sind die Gründe dafür
also der wichtigste Grund ist die hohe
Inflation die Menschen mussten deutlich
mehr für Energie und Nahrungsmittel
ausgeben und da bleibt am Ende des
Monats natürlich weniger übrig vom Lohn
deutlich sogar die Reallöhne sind so
starke Schrumpf wie noch nie seit Beginn
dieser Statistik im Jahr 2008 das liegt
aber auch daran dass das Statistische
Bundesamt nun auch kleinere Betriebe
Auszubildende und Altersteilzeit
Beschäftigte erfasst ja und deswegen
stiegen die Monatsverdienste dieses Mal
deutlich geringer als noch nach dem
alten Konzept die Zahlen sprechen eine
deutliche Sprache die Verbrauch Preise
sind 2022 um 6,9 Prozent gestiegen die
Löhne aber nur um 2,6 Prozent die
Inflation frisst das Lohnplus also mehr
als auf bedeutet
schrumpflon seit drei Jahren geht das
schon so spürbar besser wird es dieses
Jahr wohl kaum selbst in höhere Löhne zu
erwarten sind oder schon ausgehandelt
wurden denn die Inflation wird zwar
weniger aber aller Voraussicht nach nur
sehr langsam und spürbar erst im
kommenden Jahr laut ifro-institut will
noch gut jedes fünfte Unternehmen in den
kommenden Monaten die Preise erhöhen
noch ein Blick auf den DAX der tritt auf
der Stelle endet praktisch unverändert
auch gute Quartalszahlen hier in
Deutschland konnten dem Dax nicht auf
die Sprünge helfen vielen Dank Valerie
nach Frankfurt
vor dem Hintergrund einer Debatte um
familiäre Verflechtungen wichtiger
Mitarbeiter von
wirtschafts-besetzung eines Postens
überprüfen konkret geht es um den
Vorsitz der Geschäftsführung der
Deutschen Energieagentur
wirtschaftsstaatssekretär reichen habe
habe zu Wochenbeginn darüber informiert
dass der neue dehner-chef Schäfer sein
trauzeug war habe daraufhin um interne
Prüfung gebeten
bei vielen Selbstzahlerleistungen in ein
Arztpraxen sogenannten igel-angeboten
gibt es aus Sicht von Fachleuten
weiterhin Zweifel am medizinischen
Nutzen auch bei neuen Angeboten mit
Blick auf
post-55 Zusatzleistungen hat der
IGeL-Monitor bewertet bei keiner von
ihnen wurden Belege für einen positiven
Nutzen gefunden als tendenziell negativ
oder negativ wurden 29 Angebote bewertet
darunter Ultraschalluntersuchungen der
Eierstöcke und der Gebärmutter zur
Krebsfrüherkennung
nach drei Jahren Corona bedingter Pause
findet in Leipzig wieder die Buchmesse
statt am Morgen öffnete sie ihre Tore
für Besucher und Fachpublikum und 2000
Aussteller aus 40 Ländern nehmen an dem
Frühjahrstreffen der buch- und
Medienbranche Teil Gastland ist
Österreich die Messe sowie die parallel
dazu laufende Manga Comic Con und das
traditionelle Lesefest Leipzig liest
dauern bis Sonntag
so und jetzt nehmen wir Sie mit in eine
andere Welt virtuell im Netz ab ins
metaverse dorthin wo man am intensivsten
mit solchen VR Brillen einsteigt es gibt
dort ganz unterschiedliche Plattformen
und Räume und das ganze funktioniert so
man erstellt sich meist erst einen
Account ähnlich wie bei Social Media
zusätzlich bastelt man sich solch einen
3D Avatar
sieht ganz cool aus fehlt nur die
Krawatte und diese virtuelle Figur wird
dann zu meinem digitalen ich dass ich
aufmacht ins metaverse hier zum Beispiel
auf eine ziemlich bunte Insel los geht's
dort kann ich mich dann bewegen und mit
anderen Avataren Kontakt aufnehmen
hinter denen auch wiederum reale
Menschen stecken
im metavers können wir zusammen arbeiten
zusammen lernen oder spielen
alles passiert live es gibt zum Beispiel
auch Ausstellungen und Konzert
und auch eine neue Folge der ZDF-Serie
Doppelhaushälfte spielt im metaverse und
auch für alle Beteiligten dort ist das
natürlich eine Erfahrung ganz neuer Art
wie barbara-
[Musik]
Party
Lasershow bizarre gestalten
Filmszenen gedreht im meterverse zum
ersten Mal totales Neuland du bist so
cool und gleichzeitig sanft ehrlich
gesagt bei der ersten Besprechung habe
ich nichts verstanden worum es ging
jeder kennt diese Virtual Reality
Brillen direkt hat so einen ungefähren
Idee von so metaverso wir schreiben hier
tatsächlich Geschichte
Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler
kreieren ihre eigenen Avatare die sie
dann mit Hilfe von vr-brillen und
Controllern durch digitale Räume steuern
du musst kein Kostüm anziehen du musst
nicht in die Maske und hier müssen wir
nicht mal also den Text vorher zu Hause
lernen weil erst heute bekommen haben
was ZDFneo da spielerisch umsetzt
um uns alle
[Musik]
herums sehen nicht nur tech-konzerne die
nächste Evolutionsstufe des Internets
virtuelle Welten in der wir alle als
Avatare weltweit gemeinsam denken Leben
fühlen shoppen können die Vision
das all das was wir heute in der realen
Welt erleben virtuell erleben können
dass es sich aber auch so anfühlt als
wäre es real also mit allen Sinnen
inklusive Haptik und auch Geruch das
eine große meterwurst gibt es noch nicht
dafür viele kleine und alle kämpfen um
die Vorherrschaft
große Player wie der meta-konzern
ehemals Facebook investieren Milliarden
Zuckerberg wirbt in flirtenden
Werbespots für gemeinsame Arbeits- und
Erlebnisräume für eine Welt die digital
zusammenrückt egal wer wo lebt
pr-getöse Wahnwitz Fortschritt
zuallererst viele ungelöste Fragen es
braucht entsprechende Standards die dann
global greifen an die sich alle halten
wie kontrolliert man die Information wer
ist die Legislative wer ist die
Exekutive in so einem Raum damit das
keinen kein wilder Westen wird
und was ist mit Einsamkeit
mit echter Begegnung Berührung
Liebe
wie viel Technik tut uns gut wie viel
davon macht das Leben einfacher und wann
verlieren wir uns eine digitale Welt
kann so viele Elemente einer realen Welt
nicht ersetzen aber auf der anderen
Seite und das haben wir in der Pandemie
gesehen gibt es die digitale Welt nicht
einfach ganz neue Chancen schaffen
[Musik]
so oder so die Menschheit bleibt nicht
stehen rund 15 Jahre wird es noch dauern
bis die unterschiedlichen metaversen
vernetzt sein sollen und wir
wohl irgendwie mit Ihnen
so lange dauert es nicht mehr bis die
neue Staffel von Doppelhaushälfte und
das Meta vs natürlich ab morgen in der
ZDF Mediathek zu sehen sind ab morgen
und ganz real kommt jetzt gleich nach
uns die Kollegin Maybrit Illner und dort
trifft unter anderem die Sprecherin der
sogenannten letzten Generation auf den
Chef der CSU-Landesgruppe im Deutschen
Bundestag
und dann noch der Hinweis auf unser
heute schon mal Update gegen 0:30 Uhr
mit Wolf schmiese und von uns allen hier
auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter
den Kameras ein angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das Hoch lässt
allmählich nach und verabschieden sich
nach Osten aber dafür kommt dieses Tief
und dessen Fronten bringen zum Beispiel
die Warmfront in der Nacht und morgen
mit der Kaltfront dann sogar Schauer und
Gewitter eins nach dem anderen wir
schauen erstmal in die Nacht und da
kommt von Südwesten kräftige bewölkerung
auf mit Regen nach Osten hin ist es
Stern klar und dort wird es am kältesten
werden Temperaturen bis -1° Richtung
Ostsee ansonsten 10 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands dort ist es am mildesten
morgen am Vormittag dann den sich die
Regenwolken bis etwa zur Elbe aus
plötzlich davon ist es teilweise noch
sonnig mit einigen harmlosen Wolken aber
zum Nachmittag kommen die Wolken weiter
voran und dann regnet es auch in den
östlichen landeszahlen einzig Richtung
Ostsee bleibt trocken dazu gibt's dann
Zuschauer und Gewitter mit der
aufziehenden Kaltfront dazu die
Temperaturen bis 20 Grad im Westen
Deutschlands sonst in der norddeutschen
Tiefebene teilweise 11 bis 12 Grad hier
also am kältesten tagsüber die kommenden
Tage am Samstag regnet es in der
Osthälfte sonst wird es von Westen her
Trockner Temperaturen 12 bis 20 Grad
Sonntag ist fast überall trocken und das
bei Temperaturen von 12 bis 19 Grad am 1
Mai kommt dann im Süden dann regen und
Gewitter auf damit ein schöner Abend